Welcome back.
I don't like to rush too
much on these videos.
I just wanted to continue
the next one.
So what we did, I just wrote out
everything they tell us in
the problem.
We figured out x is equal to
y, so they must both be
45-degree angles.
And since y is opposite of this
angle, it must be 45.
And since this angle, this
angle, and this angle are the
same triangle and this one's
45 and this one's 90, this
must also equal 45.
And what I said is we need to
figure out this green line.
And I made the claim, and I
think you'll believe me, that
this green line is the
same length of the
line that I just drew.
This peach line, right?
And also, what else do we know
about this larger triangle?
Well, its hypotenuse is here.
Its hypotenuse is this magenta
line right there.
And let me redraw it here.
So its hypotenuse is
this magenta line.
What's the length of
the magenta line?
It's 4 plus 8.
They gave us that information.
So it's 12.
And we want to figure
out this peach line.
I'm just re-drawing it so that
you know that we're clear of
all of the mess, right?
I'm saying this green line is
the same as this peach line,
and I just re-drew this
peach line here.
What do we also know about
this triangle?
Well, if this angle up here is
45, what's this angle here?
That's also going
to be 45, right?
Because these two lines are
perpendicular, so this is 45.
And we also know that this angle
x is this angle here, so
that's also 45.
Or you can figure it
out any other way.
So there we go.
We have a 45-45-90 triangle.
We know its hypotenuse.
Can we figure out the sides?
Well we know the sides are
going to be equal, right?
Because the base angles
are equal.
We also know that in
a 45-45-90 triangle
the sides are equal.
In fact, you can even look at
the beginning of the book,
they even define a 45-45-90
triangle.
But we'll work it out just so
you see it worked out without
having to memorize.
So x squared-- this is just
Pythagorean theorem-- plus x
squared is equal to
the hypotenuse
squared is equal to 144.
2x squared is equal to 144.
x squared is equal to 72.
x is equal to the square
root of 72.
So what's the square
root of 72?
The square root of 72 is the
square root of 36 times 2,
which is the same thing as the
square root of 36 times the
square root of 2.
And what does that
turn out to be?
Well, the square root
of 36 is 6, right?
So our answer is 6 square
roots of 2.
So that is choice b.
Next problem.
Problem 8.
The price of ground
coffee bean is d
dollars for 8 ounces.
So d dollars for 8 ounces.
And each ounce makes c cups
of brewed coffee.
So one ounce makes c cups
In terms of c and d, what is the
dollar cost of the ground
coffee beans required
to make one cup?
We just want to make one
cup and we say how much
does that cost us?
OK.
So let's see how many cups we
can make with d dollars, OK?
So d dollars, we would
get 8 ounces.
So d dollars, we get 8 ounces.
And then each ounce, you
get c cups, right?
One ounce turns into c cups,
so 8 ounces will
turn into 8c cups.
But we only want
one cup, right?
So we're saying d dollars
is equal to 8c cups.
But we only want one cup, so
let's divide both sides of
this by 8c.
So what are we left with?
We're left with d over 8c
dollars is equal to one cup.
And that is choice a.
Not too bad, huh?
Next problem.
Problem number 9.
If 10/a is equal to b/12,
what is the value of ab?
So this is just straight
cross-multiplication.
a times b is equal to 10 times
12, so ab is equal to 10 times
12, which equals 120.
We are done.
120 is our answer.
If you haven't learned to
cross-multiply, it's just a
quick way-- when you see two
fractions equal each other,
you can take the numerator of
the left times the denominator
of the right.
And that equals the denominator
of the left times
the numerator of the right.
And how do we know that?
Well, we could do
it step by step.
You can multiply both
sides times a.
That cancels out and you're
left with 10 is
equal to ab over 12.
And then you multiply both sides
times 12, you get 120 is
equal to ab.
That just skips one
step right there.
Next problem.
Problem 10.
They give us a little
sequence here.
150, 30, 6, and then
it keeps going.
In the sequence above, each term
after the first term is
1/5 of the preceding term.
What is the fifth term
of the sequence?
So 1/5 of the preceding term.
So the next term is going
to be 1/5 of this.
So that's what, that's
6/5, right?
I just multiplied
1/5 times that.
So the next term is going to be
1/5 times this, so that's
6/25, right?
1/5 times 6/5 is
equal to 6/25.
So that is the fifth term.
And you could write it as a
fraction or you could write it
as a decimal, I think
you'd get 0.24 if
you do it as a decimal.
Next problem.
I'm suspicious, that
seemed too easy.
Problem 11.
Five points-- a, b, c, d, and
e-- lie on a line, not
necessarily in that order.
ab has length 24.
Point c is the midpoint of ab.
So let's draw this and
let's see if we can
avoid messing up.
OK.
So let me draw a and b.
So a, b.
This is how I'd do it if
I was taking it, taking
the test. ab is 24.
Point c is the midpoint of ab.
So point c is right here.
And it's the midpoint.
So this is 12, and this is 12.
So far so good?
And point d is the
midpoint of ac.
So this distance is 6, and this
distance is 6, right?
It's getting smaller.
I should have drawn this bigger,
but I think you get
what I'm saying.
This is point d here
in yellow.
If the distance between d and
e-- so this is d-- and the
distance between d and e is 5,
what is one possible distance
between a and e?
So they're essentially saying
where could e be?
So let me blow things
up a little bit.
Let me redraw this.
And let me focus on a and c
because that's the part that
got all scrunched up.
So if this is a, this is c, and
they tell us that d is the
midpoint of these two.
And we figured out that a to c
was 12 and a to d is 6, right?
This distance is 6, which is
the same as this distance,
that's also 6.
And then they tell us at the
end, if the distance between d
and e is 5, what is one
possible distance
between a and e?
So we know that e is on
this line as well.
So there's two places
where e could be.
e could be 5 in this direction,
it could be here.
e could be there or e could be 5
in this direction where this
is 5 and this is 5.
So if e is here, what is the
distance from a to e?
Well, this distance from
a to e is just
going to be 1, right?
You go one to e and then 5 to
d, and that adds up to 6.
So one possible distance
for ae is 1.
The other one is you go 6 to
d and then you go 5 to e.
So the other possibility
is 11.
And so, oh, this isn't
multiple choice.
You could fill out either
one of those choices.
See you in the next video.